also bei humboldt muster tag deutlich
mehr als 24 stunden gehabt haben
zumindest hat man den eindruck bei den
idealvorstellungen die dahinter stehen
dass man das individuum individuell
bilden könnte nicht nur ausbilden
sondern bilden könnte an der universität
das ist ja eine starke sehr starke
förderung
ich würde gern zunächst einmal ein paar
ganz persönliche ein paar ganz
persönliche bemerkungen machen ich
unterrichte also physik und philosophie
und habe durchaus wenn manche semestern
mehr als die hälfte meines erde portals
in philosophie das hat dazu das ist hat
eine geschichte unterrichtet seit 20
jahren philosophie an der hochschule für
philosophie und es gibt einfach
physikstudenten und zwar sogar relativ
viele die philosophie der wissenschaften
dort hören und so hat sich dann ergeben
dass ich sozusagen der grenzgänger bin
der zwischen diesen beiden für viele
deutsche offenbar gar nicht über
einzubringen manche fragen nicht wie
kommt man denn als physiker dazu
philosophie zu unterrichten sei wie
kommt man dazu dass man als physiker
nicht wieder sollten hier unterrichten
kann physik war er lange zeit eben oder
philosophie war ja lange oder physik war
lange zeit experimentelle philosophie
und viele fragen die wir in den
naturwissenschaften behandeln kommen
ursprünglich aus der philosophie und die
fragen zb auch der methoden genauigkeit
der methoden präzision der warum ist die
empirische methoden bei der untersuchung
der natur eigentlich so erfolgreich also
alle diese fragen wo es auch in grenzen
dieser methoden geht sind immer
philosophische fragen
wissenschaftstheoretiker
erkenntnistheoretische und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen dass meine tätigkeit als
physiker also als als theoretischer
physiker der sich mit komplexen systemen
beschäftigt unglaublich dadurch gewonnen
hat dass ich immer mal wieder die
perspektive einnehmen kann ich sagen ich
bin schauspieler und theaterkritiker
gleichzeitig ich kann also von außen
gucken was sie auf der bühne machen und
weiß aber auch was die auf der bühne
machen wie sie sich fühlen und das ist
also zumindest für mich die ideale
lösung geworden ich habe sie nicht
angestrebt die hat sich wie so schön
heißt einfach so ergeben ohne dass sich
eine ahnung hatte dass das jemals so
passieren wird hat sicher nicht was
damit zu tun wie ich angefangen
als studentin mich unter anderem auch
mit der philosophie zu beschäftigen was
schlicht daran lag dass in gießen die
philosophie veranstaltungen immer nach
den übungen der theoretischen physik
waren und er konnte bisher und ich werde
nie vergessen wenn die vorlesungen
naturphilosophie fast immer damit anfing
mit der sag ich werde ihnen jetzt mal
sagen warum sie physik studieren also
wir kamen von klausuren übungs blättern
und so weiter und dann kam eben jemand
daher und hat uns physik mal aus einer
ganz anderen perspektive erzählt und das
stammt allerdings alles noch aus zeiten
die viele von ihnen gar nicht kennen
also das stammt aus zeiten da gab es
noch kein bologna prozess da konnte man
noch schlendern beim studium und musste
nicht marschieren wie heute und das wird
natürlich ist natürlich die zentrale
frage als humboldt angefangen hat
darüber nachzudenken wie müsste denn wie
sollte denn ein neuer preußischer staat
aussehen und wie sollten seine bürger
sein denn aus dieser zeit stammt die
vorstellung dieses humboldtsche
bildungsideal da lag preußen ja in
tiefer agonie von napoleon besiegt und
was wird was soll nun werden aus preußen
und humboldt hat sehr sehr weit darüber
nachgedacht und sehr tief darüber
nachgedacht wie es sein müsste und hat
ein bildungsbegriff entwickelt der in
deutschland ja sehr nachhaltig geworden
ist er oft kritisiert worden dass der
blick gar nicht darauf eingehen worum es
ihm aber geht ist eine wirklich ganz
andere art von ausbildung und bildung
als wir das heute an den universitäten
durchführen
unsere universitäten haben sich
systematisch in sehr ökonomische in sehr
ökonomische systeme verwandelt wir haben
es eben schon gehört also die
drittmittel akquise ist heute wichtiger
denn je ist verspielt vor allen dingen
eine rolle wenn man also diese diese
tabellen da sieht das sieht man schon
von vornherein diesen ökonomischen
ansatz dass man schon fast so was hat
wien wien dauer wettbewerbs und der
bundesliga saison am ende des jahres wer
steht denn oben usw
dabei müsste man ja sagen auf der suche
nach der wahrheit kann es gar kein
saisonende geben
das kann ja nicht zu ende sein da gibt
es keine meisterschaft oder sowas ist
man am ende des jahres dann diese
schade da in den händen halten in den
händen hält sondern da geht es ja
offenbar um was ganz anderes
aber dieser diese art der entspannten
wirklich auch im besten sinne des wortes
entspannenden suche nach dem was wir für
wahrheit halten oder den jeweiligen
neuen gegebenheiten oder den jeweiligen
neuen informationen den neuen methoden
die uns zur verfügung stehen das ist ja
alles ganz anders geworden und deswegen
ist zum beispiel eine frage die auf der
ersten folie gegen die kann ich gleich
mal habt habt ihr das noch angeschlossen
diese die sind immerhin ich habe ich
wurde gar keine powerpoint futter halten
aber ich fand die frage die fahne schon
kann er die fand ich schon ziemlich gut
ich mache einfach irgendwas weiter also
ich wollte ursprünglich darüber sprechen
dass man den dass man diesen idealen
innerhalb von 24 stunden gar nicht
gehorchen kann aber dann sah ich schon
das war zeitmangel auf der und dann sind
wir schon mitten dabei
man kann dass man kann das im grunde
genommen so gar nicht erfüllen es sei
denn man trifft eine entscheidung und
entscheidungen sind immer
verzichtserklärung man verzichtet
nämlich auf das wofür man sich eben
nicht entschieden hat das heißt man kann
beides im nicht in gleicher qualität
tatsächlich tun und ein plädoyer für
mehr bedeutung oder für mehr respekt
gegenüber der lehre an universitäten da
kann ich allen die hier sind und allen
die das angeregt haben nur sehr sehr
dankbar sein
unter uns gesagt ich leide wie ein tier
das eine universität wie die unsrige
aber eigentlich alle universitäten sich
systematisch in ausbildungseinrichtungen
verwandelt haben
bei allem respekt gegenüber den
fachhochschulen wir haben eine
fachhochschule sierung der universitäten
wenn eine extreme modularisierung wir
haben eine extreme form von von
unfreiheit das ist nämlich tatsächlich
so was was heißt denn forschung
forschung da begibt man sich sozusagen
schrittweise in möglicherweise völlig
unbekanntes terrain unbekannteste
bedeutet vor allen dingen dass man nicht
weiß was passiert man weiß nicht was
rauskommt dabei
man hat eine ahnung man hat natürlich
ansätze die dazu führen dass man sich
eben genau diesen diesen dass man diesen
schritt wagt aber es ist eben nicht klar
ob das unternehmen was man da vorhat ob
das erfolgreich sein wird bei der
planung allerdings von forschungsgeldern
und das war zu humboldts zeiten noch gar
nicht der fall der konnte ein solches
bildungsideal entwerfen in einer zeit wo
es noch viel weniger wissenschaftliche
disziplin gehabt das war gerade die zeit
um 1800 als das in den
naturwissenschaften begann sich zu
diversifizieren es traten vor allen
dingen auch zum ersten mal historischen
naturwissenschaften auf also die
geowissenschaften alle oder die
astronomie wurde auf einmal richtig
stark die biologie alles schrie nach der
frage wo kommt das alles her das waren
ja ist eine ganz neue forderung gewesen
wie kann man naturwissenschaften auch in
dem historischen zusammenhang bringen
das war so das ist die zeit wo man wo
man beginnt auf der einen seite diese
diversifizierung der naturwissenschaften
wahrzunehmen und natürlich der beginn
der industriellen revolution
das heißt wir haben eine
industrialisierung die aber ganz anders
ganz andere ziele hat die immer
automatisch mit der ökonomie
zusammenhängt und in diesem in dieser
zeit soll nun sollen nun universitäten
etwas nach humboldts uns was ganz neues
darstellen nämlich sie sollen dem
individuum die bildung geben damit er
sich mit all den neuen entwicklungen die
noch auf uns zukommen so damals dass er
mit denen klar kommt das heißt es sollen
grundlegende ausbildung da sind es sogar
nicht darum gehen dass hier irgendwelche
bildungsinhalte gleich transportiert
werden die man dann wieder ökonomisch
nutzen kann darum geht es erstmal gar
nicht sondern diese handwerklichen
berufe das ist eine andere geschichte
hier wird es soll es darum gehen das
individuum soll sich der welt gegenüber
sehen und soll mit dieser welt auch
tatsächlich in einem engen kontakt sein
und soll eben dass dieses fast hätte ich
gesagt verfluchte wort ganzheitlich es
soll ganz sein also soll möglichst es
sollen verschiedene facetten sollen
angesprochen werden
eine große herausforderung an diejenigen
die unterrichten ein in einen
wissenschaftlichen inhalt in den großen
zusammenhang zu stellen ich halte im
nächsten semester ersetzte im kommenden
semester eine vorlesung mit dem
wahnsinnigen titel die geschichte der
natur
ja ich mir gedacht komm raus also das
ist in der tradition von carl friedrich
von weizsäcker der diese vorlesung
48 zum ersten mal in göttingen gehalten
hat und zwar deshalb weil für von
weizsäcker war es ganz wichtig
praktische verbindung zu finden zwischen
einer zentralen geisteswissenschaft der
geschichte und den naturwissenschaften
hier auf der einen seite die
experimentelle möglicherweise überall zu
jeder zeit an jedem ort reproduzierbare
naturwissenschaft mit ihren objektiven
ergebnissen auf der anderen seite aber
die historischen abläufe die eben davon
abhängig sind was davor war und diese
kontingenten anfangs und randbedingungen
die sind eben überall unterliegen
überhaupt nicht der forschung so ohne
weiteres
da muss man einfach nehmen was da ist
und er versucht in dieser in dieser
geschichte der natur vorlesung genau
diesem moment wie er das nennt kreis
gang also immer wieder aus der
geisteswissenschaft in die
naturwissenschaft zu kommen können wir
historische abläufe tatsächlich
wenigstens soweit klären dass wir ein
plausibles bild haben wie sich damals
die natürlichen vorgänge in ganz anderen
zeiten ab gespielt haben da gibt es im
prinzip der aktualität also dass es
damals schon genau so gelaufen ist wie
heute das spielt natürlich bei
geologischen fragen rolle sind wir der
kosmische durchschnitt also wenn ich
diese vorlesung halte das war zu von
weizsäckers zeiten natürlich noch nicht
so ein thema geht es natürlich auch
darum gibt es leben auf anderen planeten
gestern gab es schon physik nobelpreis
für die erste entdeckung eines planeten
um einen anderen stern
und das heißt es geht darum in dieser
vorlesung wirklich die großen linien zu
ziehen die großen zusammenhänge
klarzumachen wo stehen eigentlich die
wissenschaften in dieser großen
geschichte der natur die wir heute
naturwissenschaftlich erzählen können
aber es geht eben dann auch darum wenn
das phänomen mensch auf dem planeten
erde auftaucht gibt es neue dimension
wir haben eine neue art von geschichte
begriff eine ganz neue art von von
verhältnis von einem lebewesen zu der
natur weil dieses lebewesen in der lage
ist natur in einer form zu manipulieren
wie das vor ihm nach unserer kenntnis
zumindest auf diesem planeten noch kein
anderes lebewesen getan hat und aktuell
sind wir in der debatte anthropozän und
so weiter sind wir kommen es merken wir
ja wie diese wie diese vernunft und
verstandes maschine mensch an seine an
seine grenzen kommt weil er eben durch
die ökonomie getrieben
die ressourcen dieses planeten so
ausgenommen hat das allmählich
tatsächlich die natur sich so verändert
hat dass sie neue kontingente
randbedingungen und anfangsbedingungen
für die zukunft liefert und die sehen
offenbar ganz anders aus als noch die
randbedingungen der letzten paar hundert
jahre und das ist eine vorlesung die
meiner ansicht nach zum standard an der
universität gehören müsste und zwar im
ersten semester nach meinem dafürhalten
da stehe ich ganz in der tradition von
humboldt muss eine universität am anfang
allen studierenden die möglichkeit geben
sich einen überblick zu verschaffen und
zwar möglichst über alle wissenschaften
oder zumindestens wissenschaftsbereiche
die an der universität angeboten werden
damit einfach klar ist wo bin ich hier
was ist die aufgabe von diesem von
diesem von diesem haus von diesen
häusern von diesen instituten die ja
auch viel geld kosten also die
gesellschaft erwartet ja was erwartet
sie tatsächlich nur dass universitäten
in zuliefererbetrieb für die industrie
sind ist es das erwartet gesellschaft
von den universitäten das was sie
sowieso schon selber ist nämlich ein
durch und durch ökonomisiert betrieb ist
es das oder erwartet gesellschaft mehr
ich denke dass wir denn von humboldt mit
seinem bildungsideal durchaus ein
anspruch formuliert hat der nämlich dazu
führt dass in universitäten individuen
zu persönlichkeiten werden können die
deutlich mehr können als das was sie
können müssen was sie können müssen
gehört zu den normalen beruflichen
forderungen aber sie könnten mehr
nämlich genau dann wenn sich die dinge
verändern wenn neue herausforderungen da
sind und wenn eben mit flexibilität und
fantasie reagiert werden muss und nicht
mit den routinen den automatisierten
routinen die inzwischen ja da sind wir
mittendrin von algorithmen übernommen
werden das scheint mir der punkt zu sein
nur das klingt wirklich wie eine
eierlegende wollmilchsau
ja du sollst also alles auf einmal
machen und vor allen dingen für
diejenigen die an der universität
arbeiten möchten ist es ein nachgerade
völlig unmögliches ding das zu erfüllen
und zwar vor allen dingen heute also
wenn ich jetzt hier den in der jüngsten
zeit dieses verhältnis von forschung und
lehre hat sich in der jüngsten zeit
durch die starke normierung innerhalb
des bologna-prozesses sicherlich noch
mal verschärft
also wir haben es heute mit einem
zustand einer universität zu tun die
extrem normiert ist also auch das
quantitative geht und oft ist die frage
nach der qualität die wird hinten
angestellt also man merkt deutlich
welche kategorie
in fehler gemacht werden zwischen
quantität und qualität gibt es einfach
ein riesen unterschied man kann das eine
kann man in zahlen messen das andere
natürlich nicht das andere wird in einem
zusammenhang gemessen und hat auch was
damit zu tun was daraus wird
insofern ist hat sich das verhältnis von
forschung und lehre sicherlich in der
jüngsten zeit eher verschlechtert das
merkt man auch daran dass natürlich mit
hilfe der großen drittmittel mengen die
inzwischen den mindesten sind einige
universitäten hineinfließen sich die
kolleginnen und kollegen ja teilweise
auch von der lehre freikaufen können
die haben einfach genug geld und dann
heuer die jemanden an der für sie ihr
leergut erfüllt geht man deswegen an der
uni dann können wir auch max planck
institute gehen gibt es gibt genügend
forschungseinrichtungen in deutschland
die völlig von der lehre befreit sind
wenn es also dann wirklich darum geht
praktisch sich von der tätigkeit und ich
finde den den hinweis sehr gut dass wir
lehrstühle haben und keine
forschungsstudie fand ich dann habe ich
noch nie gehört da nicht drüber
nachgedacht dass du dich genau der punkt
die zentrale aufgabe von allen die an
der universität arbeiten ist die lehre
tut mir leid also zumindest war es für
mich immer klar ich bin ein geradezu
hirnrissig verliebter hochschullehrer
der es außerordentlich genießt zu
unterrichten und ich hatte gehofft ich
treffe mehr höre sich verliebte denen es
genauso geht
es gibt ein paar aber viel zu wenige und
das ist außerordentlich bedauerlich weil
natürlich die forschung durch die lehre
enorm profitieren kann
wissen sie es ist also mit seiner
meinung nach meiner erfahrung ist es so
man versteht das was man meint
verstanden zu haben erst dann richtig
wenn man es unterrichtet dann zeigt sich
ob das was man da sprachlich wiedergibt
mit allen digital oder sonstigen
methoden ob man das so durchdrungen hat
dass ein anderes hirn das auch versteht
und vielleicht durch nachfragen sogar
noch mitteilt das ist das genauso
verstanden habe wie man selber
verstanden hat oder aber da gibt es
diskrepanzen und man stellt unter
umständen fest oh ja das ist ja auch da
habe ich noch nie ja das ist ja auch ein
bisschen die position des kritischen
nationalisten ich kann immer mich irren
ich kann immer ein fehler machen und
dann ist es gut man ist zu zweit oder zu
dritt und kann in einem diskurs
feststellen ob die verschiedenen anderen
perspektiven hier nicht nur hilfreich
sein können mit hilfe zu klären aber
auch phänomene noch mal neu zu verstehen
und so weiter das heißt die die die
vorstellung von vielen die sich rein der
forschung ergeben nur forschung sei das
wesentliche und die lehre sei mehr oder
weniger so en passant mitzuarbeiten
halte ich für eine ganz fatale er für
eine ganz fatale fehler und ist letzten
endes glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt
das was gesellschaft von universitäten
erwartet
denn man musste durch eines sagen die
forschung ist eine ganz spezifische art
der auseinandersetzung mit der welt um
uns herum noch keine naturwissenschaften
geisteswissenschaften usw das sind ja
alles verschiedene perspektiven wie bei
uns mit der welt auseinandersetzen die
fragen die gestellt werden sind
natürlich immer fragen nach irgendwas
unbekannten mann möchte gerne wissen wie
und warum ist das so und es gibt diese
romantische phase wo es wirklich noch
rätselhaft ist und dann gibt es so eine
erste erste phase mensch jetzt habe ich
das mal so ungefähr mindestens den
einzelfall verstanden und vielleicht
kann ich es verallgemeinern
das ist eine vorstellung über den
erkenntnis wurde über den lernprozess
von von el fitr ausweitet einem britisch
amerikanischen philosophen denn ich bin
ich außerordentlich schätze und ich
glaube
dass diese romantische phase da wo es
dann darum geht auch mal zu motivieren
und wenn sie sagen von wegen relevanz
ich sei da ganz aktuell unterwegs
die meine meine kollegen vom zdf an
gestern einfach an der sternwarte und
wir haben uns das gemeinsam angeguckt
diese nobelpreisvergabe ja und dann habe
ich halt erzählt was ich das sagen kann
das war alles das waren zehn minuten
oder was ding im keller
also schnell gemacht das war überhaupt
kein problem und es ist halt wie ich
finde gehört das zu meiner lehrtätigkeit
dazu wenn ich die fähigkeit besitze oder
die die talente habe mich in der
öffentlichkeit so auszudrücken und auch
nicht jetzt irgendwie im schweiße bade
wenn die kamera auf mich gerichtet ist
dann sollte man das tun abgesehen davon
das ist ein riesen vergnügen macht aber
das ist noch mal eine andere geschichte
also ich finde dass die die tatsache
dass jemand vor anderen steht und er
oder sie dann erklärt was sie von dem
thema nun mein an essentiellen
verstanden zu haben und das dann auch
zusammen zu stellen
das ist die zentrale das ist die
zentrale aufgabe die eine universität
leisten muss möglichst viele dazu zu
bringen diese tätigkeit zu durchlaufen
und sie dann eben auch möglicherweise
sogar professionell durch zu bauen
nun aber man muss sich natürlich schon
die frage stellen wenn man sich der
forschung zuwendet was ist denn da was
er so anders und da gibt es ein problem
das kann man nicht verschweigen wenn man
in der forschung fahren mit dabei sein
will also unter anderem auch deshalb
weil eben forschung im allgemeinen ja
irgendwie drittmittel finanziert ist
muss man sich spezialisieren
also je entwickelter eine wissenschaft
ist umso spezialisierter sind diejenigen
die spitzenforschung betreiben
und jetzt ist die frage können
diejenigen die fahne zu sagen ich würde
sich so am rande des wahnsinns sondern
am rande der der jedes jeweiligen
wissensgebiete tätig sind können die
zurücktreten für eine gewisse zeit und
können aus ihrer erfahrung heraus diese
neuen erkenntnisse so in den
zusammenhang stellen bei dem
allbekannten dass sie das innerhalb von
einer vorlesung in welchem semester auch
immer dann präsentieren können das ist
auch eine frage wie an radio eriwan
im prinzip ja aber in dem moment wo man
von den forschungs inhalt zurücktritt
tritt man auch aus dem forschungsprojekt
zurück das forschungsprojekt verlangt
aber im allgemeinen eine kontinuierliche
in anführungsstrichen betreuung das
heißt ich muss ständig in der lage sein
darauf zu reagieren gibt es
konkurrierende gruppen die sich in
gleicher weise wie ich mich um
drittmittel bemühe und haben die
irgendwas was unserem modell oder
unseren vorstellungen widerspricht gibt
es nach auseinandersetzungen gibt es
einen diskurs das wäre schon schön wenn
es einen gäbe
häufig findet man es ja dann eben nur in
der literatur was hat wer wann wo wie
veröffentlicht und dann kommt aber auch
darauf an welche machtposition die man
tatsächlich ausüben würde
machen wir uns nichts vor es gibt eine
reihe von drittmittel basierter
forschung und die wird finanziert von
institutionen die nun darauf angewiesen
sind dass ist gutachterinnen und
gutachter gibt
und würden sie den antrag eines
gutachters ableiten ablehnen wenn antrag
von irgendjemandem abzulehnen ist eine
sache aber den antrag einer gutachterin
wurde eines gutachters abzulehnen
das könnte nämlich langfristig dazu
führen dass er oder sie was davon
erfährt dass sie der gutachter oder die
gutach drin gewesen sind wir reden hier
also durchaus von macht im
wissenschaftlichen betrieb diejenigen
die schon viel haben die große gruppen
haben die sind normalerweise diejenigen
die dann auch noch mehr produzieren
können und eben genau auf diesen
drittmittel weg dann immer erfolgreicher
und erfolgreicher werden machen wir uns
nichts vor so was wie die
exzellenzinitiativen machen momentan die
großen universitäten reicher und die
kleinen universitäten er ärmer ich weiß
nicht ob das eine entwicklung ist die
wirklich von von uns gewollt werden kann
dass wir also da eine so starke
zweiklassengesellschaft erzeugen das
erinnert ja alles ganz scharf für
diejenigen die sich für fußball
interessieren
an dieser champions league vereine die
einfach je häufiger die in der champions
league sind die haben einfach geld wie
heu ja da kommen eben ein paar millionen
jede saison rein die die anderen vereine
nicht haben und dass das das naturgemäß
dann auch dazu führt dass auf einmal
andere spieler eingekauft werden können
logisch ganz klar und wenn du daraus
fest da bist du weg
fenster da hast du da musste aber echt
gucken wenn du gut wenn er noch
irgendein drittmittel also ein sponsor
hast dann geht es eben den scheiß oder
was er sieht man ja oligarchen scheichs
die pumpen milliarden rein stellen sie
sich mal vor die universität münchen
hätte auch so jemanden den wir doch mal
an werten sondern irgend jemanden der
sagt 'mensch die lmu das land super
laden zwei milliarden jedes jahr das
sollte es uns wert sein also zusätzlich
zu den staatlichen mitteln und da bin
ich natürlich bei einem anderen punkt
auch da ist es etwas was für humboldt
auf interessante weise ganz wichtig war
dass der staat sich eben in die
universitäten gar nicht so einmischen
sollte eine unabhängige eine unabhängige
institution sein es sollte sogar eigenes
kapital besitzen eigene ländereien am
besten noch aus denen sie dann
tatsächlich auch von denen sie leben
kann interessanterweise habe nur die
großen amerikanischen universitäten sich
dieses symbolische ideal
die sind heute so reich wie man sich
manche von ihnen haben sogar milliarden
verdeckt in der finanzkrise und haben
das irgendwo angelegt aber damals hat
das anderer stelle sich mal vor die lmu
hatte hätte im 19 beginnenden 19
jahrhundert kapital angelegt sie können
solche entwicklungen in einem
wunderbaren roman von andreas eschbach
nachlesen
eine billion dollar heißt da da geht es
um eine geschichte das im mittelalter
ein kleiner eine ein kleines säckchen
voller goldmünzen in florenz angelegt
worden ist und der held der geschichte
der mister fontanella ein pizzabote aus
new york bekommt bekommt besuch von
einer florentinischen glaube ich
advokaten familie die mitteilt dass er
eine billion also eine europäische
billion geerbt hat weil der herr von
damals festgestellt hat es soll in 500
jahren soll es vererbt werden an den
jüngsten sohn der familie von tanja
stellen sie sich mal vor was aber alles
nicht passiert heute haben die
universitäten liegen oder dem zugriff
der staatlichen finanzierung ganz stark
wenn sie sich davon befreien kommen sie
unter umständen noch viel größere nöte
also wenn dann firmen beginnen institute
zu gründen und dann sogar nach den
entsprechenden regeln verlangen dass
dort die konferenzen ablaufen sollen
wie unlängst geschehen bei der eröffnung
eines instituts für die ethik von
künstlicher intelligenz finanziert von
facebook wo man dann
darf das ist ein public event ist
klammer auf chattem house rules klar zu
haben sie eine ahnung was steht im haus
ruf sind ich wusste das nicht
ich habe dann gelesen dass es sich dabei
um eine verschwiegenheitsklausel handelt
an einer öffentlichen einrichtung wird
ein institut eröffnet über ethik der
künstlichen intelligenz und das ganze
vollzieht sich hinter einer
verschwiegenheitsklausel sie sehen
welche bredouille an eine universität
kommen kann wenn sie eben nicht nur auf
staatliche finanzierungen zielt sondern
auch aus privaten quellen auf einmal
kommt das heißt das sind alles probleme
die humboldt versucht hat zu umgehen
indem er sagt nein die universitäten
müssen unabhängig sein von allem was um
sie herum ist sollen selber geld
verdienen können und soll mit dem geld
intern auch das machen können was
wichtig ist nämlich das entsprechende
personal die entsprechenden bedingungen
zu schaffen dass man sich eben zur
persönlichkeit bildet
persönlichkeitsbildung und keine
ausbildung ausbilden können uns andere
bilden können wir uns nur selber peter
bieri hat das ja mal so schön
aufgeschrieben wie wäre es ein
gebildeter mensch zu sein
und das hängt natürlich ganz stark daran
dass man auch die zeit hat sich mit all
den themen auseinanderzusetzen die einen
eben individuell interessieren das heißt
die forschung ist eine entscheidung wenn
sie die treffen die unmittelbar einen
zugriff auf ihre auf ihre zeit
durchführt wenn sie sich der forschung
zu wenden ganz fokussiert eine
forschungs inhalt zu wenden dann können
sie in dieser zeit eben nicht als
generalisten oder generell ist unterwegs
sein und können sich über die
wissenschaft diese studieren insgesamt
informieren sie müssen sich zwangsläufig
auf irgendwas spezialisieren das geht
also gar nicht es in keiner weise den
vorwurf das ist einfach nur schlicht der
beschreibung wie forschung funktioniert
in der lehre sind aber diejenigen die
sich eben total spezialisiert haben die
sind ein problem und zwar nicht für den
der spezialisiert ist sondern für
diejenigen die zu hören weil zu dieser
spezialisierung gehört jan weg also da
hört ja ein zeitlicher vorlauf da hat ja
jemand sich jahre wenn teilweise nicht
jahrzehnte sich mit einer sache
beschäftigt es gibt vielleicht
möglicherweise nur noch wenige menschen
auf der welt mit denen
er oder sie sich dann tatsächlich so
auseinandersetzen kann dass die begriffe
die verwendet werden von den anderen
auch verstanden werden und doch ist das
die art von forschung die wir die wir
betreiben um so wichtiger das empfand
ich immer als eine wichtige sache ist
dann eben diese forschungsergebnisse so
zu elementaren dass man sie auch der
öffentlichkeit präsentieren kann und
deswegen ist meine tätigkeit als
wissenschaftsjournalist sicherlich kein
zufall ist sie ist nicht von mir geplant
gewesen aber ich habe jede gelegenheit
wahrgenommen in öffentlichen vorträgen
immer wieder darüber zu berichten und
ich kann ihnen sagen wie astronomen
werden sehr geliebt ja also das ja weil
wir ja meistens irgendwas erzählen von
schwarzen löchern irgendwie oder
irgendwie dunkle materie und so weiter
oder von außerirdischen und das ist ja
auch alles nicht so es ist
hochinteressant aber eben nicht relevant
naja es ist in dem sinne nicht relevant
als es nicht handlungselemente ist es
greift uns nicht an in dem sinne du
musst dich aber jetzt verändern und wir
haben jetzt was rausgefunden das muss
doch wirklich konsequenz nach
wenn ich einen vortrag über den
klimawandel oder energiewende hand halte
ist die stimmung gleich gedrückt da
würde ich sagen
während ich über das schicksal des
universums da ist es alles nicht so
schlimm wenn auch wenn ich dann erzähle
eines tages wird aus dem bach
runtergehen ist die stimmung immer noch
irgendwie gut
aber wem man fängt an über das zu
sprechen was jetzt unmittelbar
möglicherweise für uns handlungs
relevant ist daran sehen sie natürlich
dass diese das ist dass es zwischen das
ist praktisch neben forschung und lehre
ja noch ganz andere bereiche gibt womit
sich universität auseinandersetzen muss
wenn sie sich mit der gesellschaftlichen
aufgaben die sie meiner ansicht nach und
zumindest nach ansicht von humboldt hat
wirklich ernsthaft auseinandersetzen
wenn sie sich nicht nur als ein
unternehmen begreift dass im prinzip so
was wie eine jahresbilanz abliefert um
am ende des jahres dann sagen zu können
das ist reingekommen und das ist
rausgekommen bei dem ranking ist nämlich
neben den drittmitteln ja auch noch die
publikation wichtig und vor allen dingen
wie es die wahrnehmung von publikationen
also wie oft wird das zitiert was da was
da publiziert worden ist und das ist
natürlich für die verschiedenen
wissenschaften die ganz unterschiedliche
methoden auch der politik publikation
haben ein riesenproblem zwangsläufig
werden die wissenschaften die dann in
einer bestimmten form publizieren und
damit natürlich auch erstens mehr
publikationen und zweitens aufgrund der
der wie soll ich sagen der der
soziologie dieser wissenschaft nämlich
wie geht man eigentlich mit den
publikationen der anderen um viel
stärker wahrgenommen also als physiker
muss man also da schreibt man keine
monographien wie schreibt man das dann
wenn man sozusagen das schlimmste hinter
sich hat also wenn man wenn man
irgendwann mal angefangen hat über ein
thema so viel zu wissen dass man sagt
okay jetzt traue ich mir zu darüber ein
buch zu schreiben sondern man arbeitet
in so einer art salamitaktik man
versucht eben tatsächlich
wissenschaftliche schritte und
wissenschaftliche untersuchung
schrittweise in fachjournalen eben in
diesem peer review verfahren zu
veröffentlichen möglichst dann natürlich
das was die anderen gemacht haben also
den konkurrierenden gruppen wahrzunehmen
und zu sagen okay das sind wir anders
machen wir dieses besser und so weiter
und so weiter das ist natürlich bei den
geisteswissenschaften wo häufig
tatsächlich erstmal jahre gearbeitet
werden muss um eine monographie wirklich
zusammen zu bringen ist eine völlig
andere situation
die dfg hat gott sei dank inzwischen
darauf rücksicht genommen aber was die
universitäts entwicklung betrifft sieht
man ganz deutlich dass die
exzellenzinitiative natürlich vor allen
dingen auf den naturwissenschaftlichen
seiten hängen und nicht bei den
geisteswissenschaftlichen was natürlich
die entwicklung innerhalb einer
universität eine katastrophe darstellt
weil die anzahl der studierenden ist in
den geisteswissenschaften natürlich viel
höher als bei den naturwissenschaften
also insofern passieren da ganz
merkwürdige schwerpunkt verschiebungen
und die frage ist wie lange
wie lange will sich gesellschaft das so
noch antun oder wird es vielleicht sogar
so sein eines tages dass wir immer mehr
und mehr spezialisierte hochschulen
bekommen werden die dann gar nicht mehr
universität heißen sondern eben
tatsächlich im wesentlichen aus bildungs
studiengänge anbieten für diejenigen
sogar die sich dann hin zu bestimmten
forschungsgebieten hinaus spezialisieren
wollen und das immer weitermachen
trotzdem würde ich sagen meine erfahrung
dass meine forschung durch die lehre
enorm profitiert hat es gehört
allerdings etwas dazu was im
zusammenhang mit mit hochspezialisierter
forschung oft gar nicht wahrgenommen
wird nämlich dass selbst da wo eine
wissenschaft meint sie hätte schon alles
durch geforscht
es wäre schon alles klar sich immer
wieder interessante nischen ergeben dass
es eben doch nicht so ist dass man
tatsächlich immer wieder zurückkehren
kann in den listen in die
wissenschaftsgeschichte und kann sich
bestimmte momente manko im moment mal
was ist denn da eigentlich passiert
ich hab das einige male gemacht und war
und habe immer wieder große
überraschungen erlebt vor allen dingen
auch in meinem umfeld weil man natürlich
dann schon merkt dass diese
spezialisierung zwangsläufig dazu führt
dass viele begriffe die ganz allgemein
in der wissenschaft um die es geht
verwendet werden bei vielen spezialisten
gar nicht mehr richtig durchdrungen sind
also die wissen wovon ist denn da
eigentlich noch so ganz genau die rede
wenn jemand eben tatsächlich sehr sehr
weit von diesen anfänger vorlesungen
oder von den ersten vorlesung entfernt
ist dann kann es interessant sein sich
einfach mal wieder zu fragen
aha ist das schon so total durchdacht
wie wir das bis jetzt gedacht haben oder
ist es eben ganz anders
das heißt um von der lehre zu
profitieren in der forschung gehört eine
gewisse offenheit dazu dass tatsächlich
das eigene forschungsprogramm oder das
forschungsprogramm des faches eben noch
nicht so hermetisch abgeschlossen ist
dass das schon alles klar ist viele der
naturwissenschaften machen ja heute den
eindruck
als sei da im prinzip schon alles
erledigt und man wisse ganz genau was da
los ist und bei der zum beispiel bei der
physik-nobelpreis von gestern gab es
neben den beiden entdeckern das ist ja
noch mal so eine richtige pionierarbeit
gewesen festzustellen wie können
eigentlich planeten wie kann man
überhaupt planeten um andere sterne
herum finden das ist eine großartige
technische herausforderung und man man
misst geschwindigkeiten um das mal zu
sagen wo die von der größenordnung sind
ungefähr so das sind die messungen das
sind die geschwindigkeiten die der stern
aus führt aufgrund der tatsache dass ihn
ein planet umkreist der wird so ein ganz
kleines bisschen aus seiner
gleichgewichts lage heraus geschoben
das kann man im licht sehen der andere
hingegen bremste er den nobelpreis
bekommen hat der hat was ganz anderes
gemacht hat theoretische arbeiten zur
kosmologie gemacht und da hatte man
wirklich oder hat man heute immer mehr
und mehr das gefühl dass überhaupt
nichts verstanden haben da gibt es
riesige fragen die aber auch erst in den
letzten zehn 15 jahren so richtig heraus
gekommen sind
aber sonst hat die physik ein
riesenproblem
sie ist extrem erfolgreich sie überprüft
ihre theorien mit einer genauigkeit dass
die verschmelzung von schwarzen löchern
und man hier machen kleinen posing
posting vortrag die verschmelzung von
schwarzen löchern in 1,3 milliarden
lichtjahren entfernung verursacht bei
uns eine längen änderung von tausendstel
protonenradius sind billionstel meter
also ich bitte sie ja das ist präzision
ja mit laser mit großen laseranlagen
dass gerade die physik als grund die
grundlegende naturwissenschaft bekommt
zunehmend den charakter auf der einen
seite von völlig ungelösten fragen
stellung auf der anderen seite von einem
kristall harten kern von theorien und
erkenntnisse die so genau überprüft
werden können wie man das so schön
beschreiben kann
da ist jemand der in new york eine
nähnadel los schiesst und jemand steht
in lissabon schießenden nähnadel los mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit die treffen sich
auf dem atlantik mit 100 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit eine nähnadel keine
stricknadel es wird so einfach das ist
die präzision mit der die teilchenphysik
bei dem beschleuniger zum beispiel im
cern messen kann
die geisteswissenschaften können von
einer solchen präzision
nun nicht mal träumen was gar nicht ihre
aufgabe ist solche präzision die
geisteswissenschaften liefern wie alle
humanwissenschaften natürlich eine
innenperspektive der gesellschaften wer
sind wir
wer waren wir wie sind wir da
hingekommen das heißt hier geht es gar
nicht um eine präzision wie sie von den
empirischen wissenschaften geliefert
werden kann und aber das wissenschafts
bild der empirischen nahm sich der
naturwissenschaften hat sich über die
universitäten gelegt wie mehltau die
große der große die große hinwendung zur
reinen empirie der vorhersage und den
prognose potenzial von diesen
wissenschaften ist zum beispiel in den
sozialwissenschaften inzwischen so weit
dass natürlich deskriptive
sozialwissenschaftler sind wir
unglaublich stark empirische studien
noch und nöcher aber normative
sozialwissenschaften
da können sie lange gucken bis jemand
finden der mann sagte also unserer
meinung nach sollte das und das
passieren wie überhaupt die politische
dimension dessen was eine universitäten
gemacht wird natürlich früher eine ganz
andere war zumindest in teilen eine ganz
andere war und humboldt sich auch
gewünscht hätte dass universität
natürlich auch in die gesellschaft
hinein wirkt aber die gesellschaftlichen
plätze wo heute diskurs stattfinden kann
wo universität tatsächlich an vorderster
front und sagen avantgardistisch mit
dabei ist das nicht der fall und warum
nicht weil es so verdammt schwierig ist
beides zu erfüllen für diejenigen die an
universitäten arbeiten und denen gesagt
wenn du sollst natürlich lehre auf
allerhöchstem niveau erstens zweitens
sollst du aber auch die drittmittel
kassieren und am besten sollten noch in
irgendwelchen forschungsverbünden
unterwegs sein und wenn du da nicht
hinreisen kannst dann hast du jeden tag
deadlines die irgendwie erfüllt werden
müssen und so weiter und so weiter
wie soll man das alles zusammen kriegen
und vor allen dingen dann hat man noch
ein zeitvertrag wie ein großer teil des
der lehre an der universität obliegt ja
denjenigen die sich vor allem gegen
neben all diesen sogenannten objektiven
verpflichtungen auch nach ihrer eigenen
karriere irgendwie zu wenn das muss ja
auch noch es muss geschrieben und
publiziert werden man muss ja
wahrgenommen werden und das ist
natürlich eine harte nummer da hat er
natürlich der gute
von humboldt als mitglied einer sagen
wir mal durchaus wohlhabenden familie
hatte davon keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
wie er dazu denken würde heutzutage dass
ein großer teil von dem was den
universitäten passiert und gott sei dank
noch passiert auf den schultern von von
menschen ausgetragen wird
bei denen die verträge absehbar ablaufen
das ist eben nicht so ist dass das da
eine sicherung da ist also dass man klar
sagen kann ja wunderbar sie sind so toll
in der lehre wir möchten sie unbedingt
behalten sondern das ist immer wieder
nur darum geht wie so einen normalen
sondern nomaden hätten hier mal was und
da mal was dieser berühmte moment nach
der promotion tue ich mir das an oder
rassisch wie also ich meine an außerhalb
der universität gibt es eine ganze menge
von verdrängen sind unbefristet
inzwischen mehr denn je sogar weil die
genau wissen wen sie da diese leute
kriegen sie nicht so einfach an der uni
kriegen sie erstmal keinen unbefristet
wird also wäre schön wenn wir da viel
viel wenn das viel klarer wäre wenn es
dann auch eine klare karriereplanung
gebe wie kann man einer universität
tatsächlich so weit kommen dass man eben
am ende nicht am ende ist es klingt ja
so fürchterlich aber tatsächlich in den
in den in den stand einer professorin
oder eines professors kommt und das ist
natürlich schon in den zeiten wo
schwarze nullen wichtig sind schulden
decken usw
bei der art und weise wie wir das in
deutschland strukturiert haben dass
universitäten ja vor allen dingen
ländersache sind wird es immer
schwieriger und schwieriger die
herausforderungen chancen und probleme
für jemanden wie wilhelm von humboldt
hätten die vieles von dem worüber wir
heute sprechen hätten die gar nicht
bestehen müssen wenn universitäten von
vorneherein tatsächlich zu so einer art
von schutzgebiet geworden wären das
gesellschafter eben nicht hineinpresst
und verlangt dass am ende eines studiums
unbedingt jemand raus kommt der jetzt
tatsächlich sofort alle fähigkeiten
besitzt und in bestimmten um einen
bestimmten beruf tätig zu werden
dafür haben wir auch ganz andere
einrichtungen geschaffen inzwischen
nämlich mit fachhochschulen und so
weiter oder den hochschulen für
angewandte
wissenschaften wie sie zurzeit wie sie
jetzt heißen und so weiter ist das ja
auch schon der fall
aber die universitäten haben sich aus
unerfindlichen gründen nicht das nicht
wirklich nachvollziehen
haben sie sich diese freiheit die ihnen
eigentlich zugestanden hat und diese
auch lange zeit gehabt haben
tatsächlich nehmen lassen und das ist
eine der größten probleme das natürlich
diese diese reduzierte freiheit sich auf
alles niederschlägt was wir an der
universität tun sowohl die in die
forschung wie auch die lehre ist davon
betroffen dass wir immer mehr und mehr
normieren de normieren de verfahren
haben normierung bei der lehre ist ganz
klar dass in diesem modul handbücher
diese diese wie heißen sie diese diese
ganzen agenturen einer köpfe
akkreditierungsagenturen genau meine
güte ja und es kostet auch noch geld das
hätten wir alles nicht tun dürfen
das hätten wir werden auf die straße
gehen müssen denn sagen müssen so soll
unsere universitäten nicht sein aber es
ist nicht passiert
und die paar hansel die sich dagegen
gestellt haben die sind dann entweder
ausgelacht worden oder ihnen ist mit dem
großen finger gedroht worden wenn ihr
das nicht macht dann übernimmt die
hochschule selbst die verwaltung ihrer
mittel so weit ist gegangen obwohl es
natürlich versuche gab das gerade von
den kleinen universitäten die haben
versucht mit den großen ins gespräch zu
kommen wenn ihr sagt ihr macht das nicht
dann können wir in ihrem windschatten
mitsegeln aber die großen universitäten
die waren schneller kolonisiert also
irgendwas anderes unglaublich und
letzten endes habe ich zumindestens in
den fächern mit denen ich zu tun habe
noch niemanden getroffen der sagt das
ist doch eine tolle sache gewesen diese
barriere fahren also so was großartiges
ja sondern alle beschweren sich nur
drüber und wenn sich mal jemand in einem
in einer zeitung richtig darüber her
macht sowohl vom hochschullehrer verband
also zum beispiel auch der deutschen
physikalischen gesellschaft und sagt ja
das ist aber doch alles da ist doch dass
auch total schief gelaufen hinten und
vorne
da wird er entweder ignoriert oder wird
gesagt ja was soll man machen
alternativlos ein lieblingswort unserer
noch kanzlerin scheint da ebenfalls sich
durch das heißt wenn man all den
gehorchen will diese idealvorstellung
von humboldt braucht man mehr als 24
stunden und brauchen mehr als sieben
tage in der woche
man braucht vor allen dingen
auch äußere bedingungen die einen dazu
veranlassen sich dem zuzuwenden also
dass es zeiten gibt in denen man eben
tatsächlich forschung betreibt und dann
wieder zeiten wo man diese forschung
eben nicht betreiben muss sondern sich
ganz der lehre zu wenden kann
es braucht zeit eine gute vorlesung in
gutes seminar durchzuführen braucht
vorbereitung in jeder hinsicht das ist
keine sache die man mal so eben so so
locker aus dem ärmel schüttelt sondern
gerade dann wenn es drauf ankommt gerade
dann wenn es geht um große vorlesung
wird es darum gehen über übersicht zu
halten und eine übersicht zu geben und
das auch in den zusammenhang zu anderen
fächern zu stellen das wäre natürlich
wunderbar die vorstellung eine vorlesung
zu halten die ihm zeigt wo steht meine
wissenschaft eigentlich im vergleich zu
anderen wo steht so eine
wissenschaftliche sieg und wenn ich und
so eine folie sowie geschichte der natur
ist so ein versuch sie genau da hin zu
stellen zu gucken wo sind die anderen
naturwissenschaften wo stehen die
sozialwissenschaften im vergleich zu dem
was daneben in technischer form zum
beispiel aus der grundlagenforschung aus
der naturwissenschaftlichen
grundlagenforschung rauskommt was machen
wir denn diese invasive technisierung
die wir jetzt in den letzten jahrzehnten
erleben ist ja kein zufall sondern ist
ja der tatsache geschuldet dass wir
immer mehr verstanden haben wie wir
materien manipulieren können dass sie
eben genau die eigenschaften besitzen
die wir gerne haben wollen und das hat
damit zu tun dass wir grundlegende den
20er und 30er jahren verstanden haben
wie materie aufgebaut ist wenn sie ihren
digitalen diktator anschmeißen nachher
dann ist das in ihrer handels
quantenmechanik ja da kommt das her
das heißt das ist tatsächlich ein fast
unmöglich das ist unmöglich es sei denn
man hat eine dauerstelle
und jetzt komme ich zum schönen teil des
vortrags
sehen sie zu dass in der dauer stelle
gelegen und zwar so schnell wie möglich
dann können sie machen was sie wollen
hallo kamera dann könnte ich sie machen
was sie wollen da steht nämlich im
grundgesetz artikel 5 forschung und
lehre sind frei
das ist der punkt da steht in unserem
grundgesetz
nehmen sie sich regelmäßig im
grundgesetz mit wenn irgendjemand wieder
was von ihnen forderte hier
da das meine ich völlig ernst sie lachen
aber ich meine es völlig ernst die
freiräume die uns das grundgesetz
da gibt es sind geben es ist unglaublich
ich bin seit 1995 professor hier an der
lmu und ich hatte oder habe immer noch
liebe kollegen die mich sozusagen in
diesen freiheits raum universität
hineingeführt haben ich komme von dem
max-planck-institut ich war am max
planck institut für radioastronomie in
bonn und habe einen wesentlichen teil
meiner meiner forschungsarbeit in den in
den ersten jahren am mpi verbracht also
in anführungsstrichen noch nicht nur an
fünfstelligen paradiesische zustände
über super ja und wenn dann 995 hier an
die lmu gekommen und hatte tatsächlich
kolleginnen und kollegen die mich
praktisch da hineingeführt hat er gesagt
haben guck dir das an welche freiheits
räume zur verfügung stehen wir wollen
erstmal gar nicht von dir dass du jetzt
hier drittmittel an land ist wie folgt
der guckt er an lassen das machen wir so
und ich hatte dann das riesenglück eben
über gute freunde an der hochschule für
die hochschule für philosophie kennen zu
lernen und dann habe ich natürlich was
gemacht wie es so schön heißt das war
einigermaßen mutig hat eine ein kollege
immer zu mir gesagt
dann habe ich einfach angefangen da mit
einem kollegen zusammen seminare
anzubieten und die standen auch im lmu
vorlesungsverzeichnis über
selbstorganisation zum beispiel da war
auf einmal im lmu physik war was über
selbstorganisation in der biologie drin
christian kummer und harald lesch an der
hochschule für philosophie standen polen
verzeichnis und wenn wir das seminar
gemacht haben und vorträge da waren
konnte man wurden die scheine anerkannt
und so ging es immer weiter das heißt
ich kann allen nur raten wenn wenn diese
freiheit räume die es tatsächlich gibt
auszunutzen zu dingen einfach mal
auszuprobieren zu gucken selbst so ein
thema wie lehre und forschung zum
seminar thema zu machen und zwar in
ihrem speziellen fach was könnten sie
jetzt aus dem woran sie jetzt forschen
innerhalb einer vorlesung direkt
verwenden wo findet das statt ich kenne
einige kollegen aus zum beispiel aus der
theologie genauso wie aus der
philosophie dass die das so machen also
mit mit denen ich auch zusammen die
seminare gemacht habe oder immer noch
mache nächste woche findet ein seminar
von armin greiner und mia kamin ist
katholischer fundamentaltheologe und
mehr statt über die warum ist mathematik
so wahnsinnig erfolgreich in der
beschreibung der natur
es gibt es natürlich mehrere gründe das
hat man so ein seminar anbietet eines
ist der abend und ich sind gute freunde
und auf diese weise sehen wir uns
garantiert im semester jede woche einmal
garantiert und wenn wir vorher noch
zusammen essen gehen kann man das heißt
es gibt diese ganz persönliche
komponente die sie unbedingt fliegen
sollten dass man sich nicht dass man
nicht als fremdkörper sozusagen in der
universität sich herumtreibt sondern
suchen sich freundinnen und freunde mit
denen sie so was zusammen machen können
das ist für mich war
interdisziplinarität das sage ich ihnen
ganz ehrlich funktioniert nur auf einer
basis wo man sich sehr wohl gesonnen ist
das funktioniert nicht in der form von
institutioneller verordnung da kommen
sie nicht sie müssen das was jemand tut
muss sie interessieren und sie würden
gerne wissen warum macht der oder die
nicht das was ich mache und wenn arjen
und ich ein seminar erhalten und dann
ist im laufe des semesters oft die frage
warum bist du eigentlich physiker
geworden und du hast du das auch
theologe werden können also man muss es
man muss das mögen was die anderen tun
man muss sich dafür interessieren und
mögen und das ist natürlich eine sache
die man auch nicht verordnen kann und
die eben dann auch nicht quantitativ
messbar ist sie können freundschaft
nicht per dfg antrag zusammen bringen
aber wenn zwei freunde man dfg antrag
stellen dann kann was daraus werden
also insofern kann ich wirklich alle nur
ermuntern und für humboldt war das ja
auch ein wichtiger punkt diese humane
dimension
und der universität immer wieder zu
betonen raus aus diesem quantitativen
irrsinn der uns pausenlos bedrängt mit
cds punkten und drittmitteln und so
weiter und deadlines und alle möglichen
die universität zu einem lebensraum zu
machen wo diejenigen die unterrichten
die ihnen die hier studieren und
unterrichtet werden sich wohlfühlen und
als personen eben wahrgenommen werden
als individuen nicht irgendwie nur so
durchlauf so dadurch laufen und einfach
die matrikelnummer sohn so sind das ist
natürlich in manchen fächern fast
praktisch unmöglich und wird durch die
zunehmende veränderung von denen ich
vorhin gesprochen habe auch fast immer
unmöglicher aber versuchen kann man es
und das ist die einzige chance die wir
haben das natürlich da wir wissen wie
ein ideal aussehen könnte und das
humboldtsche bildungsideal ist so eins
können wir zumindest versuchen ein paar
kleine schritte dahin zu machen bei all
den gegenbewegungen das erinnert mich
ein bisschen jetzt daran wie das ist in
meinem bayerischer klimarat ist und
monatelang versucht hat in der
bayerischen politik die leute dazu zu
bringen bei einem klimaschutzgesetz also
tatsächlich mal was zu machen
was danach aussieht dass es auch sich
tatsächlich lohnen könnte also dass da
was wirksames rauskommt ich habe jetzt
ein paar wochen hinter mir wo ich mich
so viele wie so ein landsknecht der
irgendwie von der schlacht von einem
schlachtfeld so runter hoppelt mit so
großen so großen stelzen und ziemlich
angeschlagen ist war nichts dabei
passiert ist aber was ist die
alternative ja wir können die lage
feststellen und einer meiner freunde ist
ein arzt gesagt hat was würdest du von
einem arzt verlangen
der vor einem patient steht von dem er
weiß der hat nur eine ganz kleine chance
würdest du das heißt soll er davon
rennen sondern in depression verfallen
ein schaut sich an was hat wasser hat
wird ruhig bleibt cool und ist mutig und
das finde ich ist bei vielen in vielen
lebenssituationen wo solche solche
offensichtlichen widersprüche da sind an
denen man versucht zu arbeiten glaube
ich schon die richtige haltung und ich
bin erstmal wirklich ich finde es toll
dass wir dass wir diese veranstaltung
habe ich finde dass dozierenden netzwerk
eine großartige sache
ich hätte mir als als privatdozent an
der uni in bonn hätte ich mir das sehr
gewünscht also wir haben alle mehr oder
weniger alleine vor uns hin gemacht
und viele von meinen kollegen sind dann
auch eben nie in die wissenschaft
gekommen und das ist nie in die in die
in diesen die in die lehre gegangen
im wahrsten sinne des wortes auch nie in
die lehre gegangen um zu lernen wie man
lernt diesen öffentlichen oder diesem
raum hier vorne auszuhalten ohne dass
man gleich das gefühl hat oh gott oh
gott ich wie sie wollen jetzt von mir
was hören und so weiter also die das
also da kann ich nur alle ermuntern dazu
hier
und sie alle ermutigen das ist eine
tolle sache dass weiterzumachen
ich habe ihnen keine lösung anzubieten
nur die eine bleiben sie mutig bleiben
sie dran bleiben sie gelassen es gibt
diesen city fonds der heute jedes mal
wieder diese kugel da jeden tag hoch und
es wird uns ja immer nur erzählt dass es
ebenso eine harte arbeit ist diese kugel
der hoch zu freuen
aber haben sie schon mal gefragt wird
macht er eigentlich danach was macht der
nachmittags ja wenn er die kugel der oma
da musste wieder runterkommen und das
scheint mir im moment zu sein den wir
uns immer wieder gönnen sollten bei all
den ganzen problemen die wir an der uni
haben es gibt diesen moment wo wir von
oben herab und das meine ich jetzt gar
nicht von oben herab sondern nur in
einem ganz bildlichen sinne über diese
landschaft schauen können die wir werden
in unseren fächern so mögen deswegen
haben wir angefangen diese fächer zu
studieren und deswegen unterrichten wir
sie jetzt auch und diese liebe zu diesem
fach
die sollte man nicht verlieren bei all
den ganzen problemen die wir jeweils da
haben den ganzen wagen praktischen
problemen das ist das was auf andere
menschen überspringt das ist das was ich
glaube wenn es eine untersuchung geben
sowie in der schule wo man
herausgefunden hat die lehrerinnen und
lehrer sind die entscheidenden faktoren
für das was mit mit den schülerinnen und
schülern passiert ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher ob man das auf die universitäten
so ohne weiteres übertragen kann
aber ich fände es schön ist vielleicht
naiv aber so ist es nun mal
ich bin ein naiver ideal ist ja danke
schön
[Applaus]